welcome to this video playing vitae
water from Argentina Kings Indian I
could I could play c-54 change on ok
let's uh I'm sorry I should have let see
how ok now i have to defend the the
exchange which is not the most terrible
thing but some it's not exactly exciting
usually for black check ok yeah i had i
had this on the board i had this on the
button in another game while ago and I
really got into I got into trouble
yeah I cuz I thought I couldn't take
because of the seven so let's see how to
play that
I want I need to protect 87 at some
point a plane i def 896 these kind of
ideas
and okay is he going to play repent see
5 or not I could play c5 myself so yeah
maybe this isn't so bad I don't like him
to place the five okay
of course it doesn't really improve the
bishop on g7 but the idea is to to play
Knights e7 e 64 the 96 than to d4 yes
you can always exchange his bishop mya g
form
I wonder if 96 can be an idea taking you
for and ce4 I oh I OSS 92 so 96 is Sam
not helping at all
yeah the position is very closed why
does some certainly a bit more
comfortable that that's clear but it's
um it's not easy to make progress as
wide I simply cannot do do anything just
sit and wait yeah not a very successful
opening if you just can play for sit and
wait something something went wrong but
it's not the terrible position it's
something you should be able to to
Howard okay night is probably on its way
to our to see three
need to get some counter plane may be
trying to play against if he takes
Bishop takes I have ideas to exchange it
with Bishop g5 and if he plays h4 I take
take and then Bishop F 87 taking g5 this
is actually slightly exposed to spawn
this is X this is the only bit of
counter play that I have so what i said
earlier that i have no play at all this
is not quite sure this is the only let's
sort of mini idea that that I have yeah
I think taking was better than allowing
me to take and to know Bishop g5 young
get to get this this Bishop into the
game this night f4 move or is it bad I
can also play h5
now kept this shouldn't be he shouldn't
be too awful Knight c3 or any anything I
can I have 93 checking be too and after
okay yeah this I thought is not a threat
I can advance the King first no he needs
to be careful now this can easily turn
into my favor I have with g 5 h four
patents potential passport
yeah night is six
first first stage for you is better ok
so now how to i need to activate the
noid Knight f6 96 coming
yep yep Black's plex better now
h5 is my destination
I thinking now King g2m okay let's
consider for a moment night h5 is going
to play King age 3 yakin I could play
Knight age 72 g five but that's not so
great
hmm did I was playing in some way and
possible check
probably didn't didn't play it in the
best way possible now this is this is
good dis good now though check at the
end I I have the night against the poems
time morning white forfeits on time yeah
he lost the threat in the end game I
think you're onto yet it's probably it's
probably around equal I don't think I'm
in big trouble anymore I had some doubts
but what you can always do instead of
like f3 can always just just grab this
and play this type of position with 925
I mean this is probably about equal
maybe why this um what white looks a bit
better because of the bishop but i
always have bishop 225 and it is a very
close position hard to tell if why it
still has something the computer says
that equal not not sure but this this
already is is getting getting
comfortable and exchanging into this end
game is dangerous here black is already
better maybe h5 was was not precise I
could I could have played this this
before activating the night maybe that's
better I not not sure
perhaps I keep pressing this annoying
again it's it's it's probably probably
very very difficult for him to hold yeah
this lost lost straightaway but this
this is probably what needs to be done
check and this is some this is probably
a win for black in the long run with all
the points on light squares against the
night i get i get to i get i'll enter
the position it just takes a while night
somewhere here then entering with the
king alright thanks for watching